welcome crafting videos that's right
Edgar we're making a crafting video but
not for you Edgar go away go away Edgar
this is not your video hi doggie so we
got doggie we had him for a while but I
never showed him on my channel
he's a hedgehog so obviously we have a
hedgehog he's really fast as you can
tell but you know what I say
not fast enough obviously doggie needs
his sonic classic shoes basically I
didn't know what the film today might
says like why don't you craft something
so we're gonna make some shoes for doggy
so to make Sonic's shoes we have some
red felt some thicker to make the sole
we get the yellow and we got the whites
and in fulfilling real crazy we'll make
him a hat as well I've literally never
crafted anything in my life so I don't
know why I thought I was qualified to do
this but here we go
okay so we're gonna grab the sole this
is like a thicker plasticky thing might
see I went and bought it at the craft
store with me we went to the craft store
for this video okay we got one sole done
we are working with extreme precision
here okay this is not some kind of sad
Sunday dy I do D DIY you think that's
funny so there we go
we got we got two of the soles done my
approves do you approve Maya
I think that's a yes okay so the next
step is that we need to make the that
the front bit of the foot all right this
bit you know if this is I'm making it
for myself it would be this bit you know
I'm saying do you understand me I need
to match the this bit with the sole okay
so we're gonna trace it and we're using
them more fabricated and I'm gonna go a
little bit on the outside cuz we need it
to be a little bigger right Marcia is
that Cray see that was intuition years
what would previously take years of
knowledge took me literally just by my
intellect to figure out myself you know
people go to school they go to crafting
school I didn't even go to crafting
school so you know that stupid you laugh
you loose video where there's a hedgehog
there's someone rubs the belly of their
Hedgehog well that's why we have a head
shot case anyone is wondering we've all
looked at it and we would like that so
cute we want a hedgehog now so there you
go that's how you get a head shot okay
now we're gonna yeah no no this looks
like sonic shoes if you ask me
alright a little secret glue gun glue
gun all the pros use them all the pros
look at Maya she uses one and while the
glue gun is heating up we're gonna
figure out there's the top there's the
top bit that goes over as well we're
gonna cut that out
it requires extreme precision and
constant concentration this is basically
like I'm playing cuphead right now
that's how difficult business video game
journalist would not be able to do this
we're getting there dude I'm like
already proud but I know what you're
thinking okay this isn't hold this
doesn't hold at all oh go away there you
go
got it you got to be able to keep up if
you're going with PewDiePie's crafting
my new channel it's my new channel is
also an original joke made by me no
other youtuber has made this joke about
making a crafting channel and then not
actually doing it
there we go so we're gonna cut a hole
for where the footsies go in right right
that's why we're doing this right so I'm
just gonna my said I know my amazing do
I call me to me oh yeah but that's how
many shoes to sunny cab
where's ya how's this hole is that a
good hole that not too small her phrase
little feetsies it's kind of fun never
crafted in my life before another stroke
of genius that I got it's that you know
now we made the soul a little too small
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
glue it on the inside out which is what
I came up with myself number this is my
idea this is it this is how you explain
it goodnight
look at that oh wait oh oh no oh it's
really hot
ow are we so as you can see here with my
hands I am adjusting the other shoe this
is the one my step try to help me win
and this is the is the one I'm doing I
should have made them for you my instead
there would have been way easy okay so
as you can see it we're gluing I'm
gluing with great precision we're hard
at work over here being busy being
crafty be cool all right
you can see here a clear improvement
guess which one is mine you know what
don't worry about it
come on nice
we're not done we have to add the sock
sonic has a little sock on him how are
you so good at the glue gun cuz like
when I press it so much comes out sonic
who fan are you have any sonic fans Oh
you best okay quickly quickly quickly
quick look at that sonic shoe man yeah
melted skin from the speed of these shoe
why do I get so much glue I don't get it
man
crafting sucks man this is for doggy
okay
our beloved child he needs this you may
wondering what I'm doing I'm making an
egg a ring okay I'm making a ring
because we know sonic loves rings and we
don't know he actually he loves your
jewellery doesn't he
oh my god sonic doggy loves rings as
well that looks like a ring this is like
an homage to all them like sonic memes
or whatever they didn't turn out that
bad right it could have been worse I
think for my very first crafting this is
part 1 out of 500 by the way this is I
this came out of clean now that I know
where you're asking are those actually
gonna fit his feet probably not no he's
a little grumpy right now he's is
looking at me like what the hell
sea salt spiked up right now he's got
one in his head there we go hey look
what we got you oh we should probably
have measured because these are too
small you don't like the shoes doggy
what I tried this is my first crafting I
haven't even crafted for Eddie please
love me small good no doggy do you like
the ring okay so uh mines yeah you did
this you made another pair because we
ran out of battery in the camera
oh this fits pretty good as you can see
this was a great idea
are you serious we did two pairs and
none of them faint are okay let's put on
his stupid hat then battle while you
were busy crafting murder yeah I made
this very beautiful Sonic hat which I'm
sure he will absolutely adore so that
was one of many series if anything you
guys know got to see doggy a little bit
maybe next time we'll do something for
sleeping this is
crack crack crafting with pills and I
will see you in the next episode goodbye
he wants to sleep here he was sleeping
here before suck you squat BAM ciao
[Music]
okay since that was a complete failure
and the Hat was the best thing right I
know what you're thinking sleepy needs a
hat right so we're gonna make a hat for
slippy because he's been asking me for a
long time he's like feet feeler come on
man aren't you making me a hat so I can
wear so we're gonna cut off this little
piece this is gonna be the front of the
Hat like you know the cap it would be
cute of hats where this tiny alright
this is gonna be the front of the Hat
this is some supreme sleepy as the
hype these people don't know we're gonna
glue that I feel like I know what I'm
doing this time you know I mean I know
what I'm doing every time okay so now we
have a little bit extra don't worry
extra is okay because then we can cut it
out
just like I cut out my marriage Maya is
so jealous that we are filming this
she's like why are you not filming me
extreme precision when I do this try and
keep up in case if you have a toad or a
hedgehog this is a great tutorial that
you can do yourself okay we're gonna put
the glue on the edge of the thing this
is the weirdest bit how did PewDiePie
end up here I am I just want to
apologize to the DIY community on
YouTube it's starting to look like a cap
we as you can tell we have a little bit
extra but why did we say
extra is good what's wrong with this
what's wrong with this you and why this
I'm gonna grab a white marker to get the
supreme logo on it drop very carefully
this is really hard I'm actually focused
[Music]
make pretty pike right again I have to
skip out on a ladder and it's kind of
like a tweet she looks like Super Mario
so cute all right here we go
I'm so excited okay slippy how you doing
buddy I see now immediately that I
overestimated your size oh my god oh my
god
it actually worked he loves it he's not
pooping or anything
he looks extremely angry he's like what
is on my face dude oh my god
they worked I'm I'm a crafter I'm a
crafter confirm that was it I'm
exhausted
I'm so tired that's it for me for now
squad flame out